and what did you eat for breakfast this
morning dude today i had scrambled eggs with
black coffee i usually
have coffee here in this cafeteria that
we affectionately call him 11
but today i had coffee at home just
like you went to  school today as
usual You go to school today I came
in my car right but usually I
usually ride Green with two friends
teachers that teacher Deise and
teacher Cris baiana How much time do you
spend from home to school so the
distance from my house that  I live in
Guará and here in the inpatient unit it
is in Santa Maria It's 27 km, you know, it's more
or less how we get against the flow for
about half an hour to get here,
if you don't, mentality when you enter the school,
all
good, so the environment that I  I'm going to the class
at the inpatient unit, you'll see
the youngsters are actually serving a
socio-educational measure of deprivation,
so it's a place of a lot of suffering, it's
a place that has a lot of attempts to  and
suicide is a place that has a lot of
self-mutilation so the feeling that I
have as a goal is always a feeling of
alterity of trying to put myself in the place
of these teenagers who are deprived
of their freedom and what suffering must be
their day to day and she  It's a Challenge
even though I put it to myself
daily when I enter the unit
I try to provide a more
relaxed moment more joyful more welcoming
teenagers price for you their passage
through this place is a little smoother
with this mentality that I enter the
school in my day to day is not something
you love Friday in the safe area where your
school is So it's actually the
inpatient unit it's in the rural area
here in Santa Maria so you can
see that there's nothing in the mediations right the
not being bush practically so there is
no public apparatus there is nothing
good so here I can say how the
strong point of this school community is the
school community itself are the
boys and girls who are coming to
detained that is society often
sees them as violent as
violent but in fact we are
suffering various forms of violence
since the first years of life who is
your favorite movie star of favorite movie
I won't name  one I will
mention two actually a couple that I
admire a lot that is Lázaro Ramos and
Taís Araújo are two black actors and
in addition to being excellent actors they are
excellent people
I can singer
the singer favorite band once again I
will use parity
I'm going to quote a rap that I have so I
'm very proud to say that because
the people I admire the most today have
become my personal friends, so
this rappi is something considered the
poet of the National Rap that is the gob that
so he his songs his lyrics
was a college for me much
more even than my
history college come on hero
the guy is hard they are very hero
and  m i think i have to speak in the
plural of my heroes and my heroines
a i think my greatest heroine
is my mother right my mother single mother right
she raised me and my older brother that
41 years ago my older brother who  43
who raised practically alone she
separated from my father I was two years
old she is also a history teacher
now retired like me who raised people a
lot of difficulty But with great
dignity she also knows where you
would like to be where I
would like to visit
Yeah, but if I were you, I'm just one,
I'd like to meet Cubans Because
despite people talking very badly about guilt,
etc. I think we Brazilians
need to learn a lot from them
about having a simpler way of life
and having other priorities.
why do we have
origami what we manage for
example health and education are not
valued as they should be What is
your favorite subject at school my pro
component cu  rricular already denounces right
History I always had many good
history teachers my mother the
history teacher too so follow
in my mother's footsteps
and what was her least favorite subject
in math school I had a lot of
difficulty with numbers right to this day
I have  this difficulty actually I
go beyond difficulty But
anyone blocking this speaking the
truth has a block regarding
all sciences involving many
and what kind of student you were at
school Amazingly the
people who have been speaking in public  with
a certain ease with a certain
ease and ask forever curled up
like this to talk to you right but he's not an
extremely shy student you don't
really move What was your
favorite food in the school canteen dude my
favorite food is very simple
actually and she me  reminds me of
rice with sardines because the voice with
sardines my mother used to
make rice with sardines for me too  to
my brother she had little time to
cook because she, as I said,
teacher of history but only and she had
Regency in the morning in the afternoon so
lunch time then I'll do
something improvised What time do you
usually leave school
well then  here at the Regency we also have
two shifts, morning and afternoon, here her class
, but she didn't have it, it starts at
8:00 is a word from this school next door,
here it starts a little later
because the boys try to have a
protocol to follow, right the agents
need it  search him sex take him out of the
module and move to school then
this procedure that takes a
certain time then as the class
starts to circulate the others how to get
here around 7:30 or 7:45 at least there
to be able to enter the classroom  class and I
stayed all day, she leaves here at
and when the afternoon hours end And
then around 16:15
pm the class ends at 18:15, right, the
non-material organism and the episode on
my side  o again
if you usually Keep working
When you get home, you talk a lot,
cook things because it's a trend
because it reminds me of my Regency of
my discipline that the history we
move the project must, right, we
use several artistic languages
edagogical tool so it's
always planning the soiree or uses
a conversation circle so there is
always a contract there that by the
apps looking for what they were
artist with a tour a speaker is
the one looking to make the air Goal of the
dissemination of Rezende so like this
actually Not for right I need
discipline in relation to this that
sometimes I get a little pulling at
home because I mix
in moments of leisure work and what do
you do to download
the music always had the music always
marked me like that when I was 12 years old He
already  LG so you're going to make a gift
to music and literature Marginal right or
peripheral literature
emergency temperature but neither  literature made in the
periphery and for the periphery so
the next to read with the old sexual
Nelson map Cristiane Sobral boy
bonds and often it is also a
privilege to pass from cloth friend
also I think I am privileged
in the sense
and what are they  passion the hobby and flower on
top is a really communist song already at
12 years old it's cool that's right that I
arrive in the United States current there
's no way it presents in the city right and I
'm going to Grande Cidade was a DJ too that's
very cool which one  Your Achievement look at
education that you are proud of as
in many but there is a specific one that reminded me a
lot that it was a year in 2018
that we received a national award to
present the misery and
zoo abbreviation here to put on the channel a
possibility or socio-educational and to
boys and girls to show that
they have safe protection could you
write a motivational sentence to
Fábio what would it be let's do this test
is a problem option  here here And let's
go back here so this would be the phrase
head and there as a message for my
EA students Let's go And then I'm going to reset it
also in rap format, right,
wherever you are, whatever it is, have faith
because even in the dump, flowers are born
and it's a phrase from is an excerpt from a
song by Racionais MCs called the
crazy life and I think it represents a lot of
the context where the new lipstick right What is the
most important advice you would
give your students
the advice I think is to continue
dreaming never give up dreaming i
remember when i got here five
years ago my first contact
with the boys and girls i
asked him about their dreams and i was
very frustrating for me because i had
realized that they had  lost the
ability to dream and this is very
sad, right because dreams they
transform, right, it makes
us move, it makes us
verbalize what we are feeling
and finally what the teacher has become  Sor
and I'll remember when you asked this
question Raquel once he was with
the poet Sérgio Vaz
and what did he become a poet and he
replied that it's because he was a coward
the game I identified with the answer kinda
I think I'll come back  for people because
I'm healthy is when we go
through the history faculty, you know, they study for
four years the graduation history
about
me, I've already made this revolt, you know, people because
we play to learn how, throughout
the historical process, man ended up
becoming his own preacher  ended up
becoming a new one in red so the
man is killing a man the
castellano man man against us right
is we show much safer than
sources we aggregate more than
aggregating income concentration few
with a lot and many a little  So this
generates revolt in us and it made us happy when
I graduated, I fed adolescence the
desire to take it but not make a revolution
and I even use a snippet of a song
by Sandrox there v  Take the fact
that despite this really burning
in the Pacific heart So I think
my hand of making revolution was
using the brush instead of a rifle, right, it
was using the classroom instead
of the Battlefields it was suddenly
fighting not with  not fighting vacations
but fighting on ideas fighting a
knowledge in the narrative dispute
So I think that's it I think I'm the
arm to take and you don't know then but
you just evolve in another way and